hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich habe bereits zahlreiche Male
auf kahoot Quizes reagiert und noch
heute haben wir wieder die drei Fanpages
con__loogie logi
der_loten Fragen Handeln fangen wir
direkt an mit dem ersten Quiz von Malin
vor wie vielen Stunden hat Luca sein
erstes Youtube-Video veröffentlicht
[Musik]
bodenloses Bild hier mal wieder wie viel
Stunden habe ich mein erstes Youtube
Video veröffentlicht ich glaube es ist
ja mindestens 10 11 Jahre her das heißt
es sind ja locker schon mal an die 4000
Tage und 4000 mal 24
sind so knapp 90.000 also ich würde
sagen 104000
[Musik]
ich hatte Mathe LK hatte ich eigentlich
gar nicht aber ich bin schlau
Frage Nummer zwei wie viele Minuten geht
Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 insgesamt
[Musik]
wie viele Minuten geht Minecraft Staffel
1 okay also wir hatten 100 Folgen nehmen
wir mal an eine Folge ging im
Durchschnitt 15 bis 20 Minuten dann
haben wir 1500 ich würde sagen 1800
Minuten
[Musik]
Alter das sind im Durchschnitt 18
Minuten pro Folge um mehr Werbung zu
schalten muss ein Video mindestens 8
Minuten gehen das heißt ich hätte mit
Minecraft Lukas Staffel 1 das Doppelte
verdienen können wenn ich 200 Folgen
gemacht hätte müssen wir überlegen
Frage Nummer 3 von 7 wie viele Youtube
Videos hat Luca 2020 ins
bodenlos lasst doch mal diese blöden
Mobbing Bilder weg wie viele Videos habe
ich 2020 insgesamt hochgeladen die Sache
ist dass ich glaube ich 2020 meinen
zweitkanal Luke wo er aktuell nahezu
daily Videos kommen könnt ihr auch gerne
mal vorbeischauen aktuell die Videos
während ich im Urlaub bin da war ich
glaube 2020 nicht so ganz aktiv deswegen
würde ich sagen
kamen 320 Videos
255 nur
okay also es gab mal Jahre 2019/20
hochgeladen mittlerweile lade ich mehr
hoch als 365 Videos im Jahr eben
aufgrund Haupt und zweitkanal aber das
war halt 2020 noch nicht so vor wie
vielen Tagen kam die erste Folge von
Skyblock mit Luca online boah ich glaube
das was sie mir hier erstellt haben das
Quiz es ist schon ein paar Wochen alt
deswegen muss ich safe noch mal so 30
Tage drauf rechnen so oder so bringt
mich das nicht eher an die Antwort
einfach mal 256
[Musik]
danke dritt letzte Frage vom ersten Quiz
an welchem Tag ging das Video mit den
meisten aufrufen online das ist so Irene
mein Video mit den meisten Aufruf ist
einfach ein Vlog er hat uns bedroht wo
ein kleiner Junge uns einfach anschreit
so auf dumm habe ich geschrieben er hat
uns bedroht der hat uns gar nicht
bedroht und dann immer gesagt ich habe
ein Messer oder so aber halt aus jokes
hat einfach 10 Millionen Aufrufe Alter
so krass ich glaube
ey was ist denn das eigentlich die
ganzen Tage sind nur zwei Wochen
auseinander das kann ich ja nur raten
sorry aber das ist viel zu schwer bei
wie vielen Videos ist Sandra auf dem
thumbnail zu sehen boah ey das sind so
unfassbar schwierige Fragen ich glaube
ich habe tatsächlich noch gar nicht so
viele Videos miteinander gedreht ich
würde sagen 81
1 2 oder 3
letzte Frage eine Antwort stimmt nicht
weißt du welche der Kanal Laser Luca
bietet reactions Minecraft Videos
qualitativ hochwertigen konnte
[Musik]
Mobbing das gibt eine Anzeige schauen
wir uns mal das Rating an für das erste
Quiz was wir heute gemacht haben Shiva
auf der drei wir haben den ersten Platz
eventuell noch drin auf der 2 Robin bin
ich erster
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe nicht damit gerechnet dass ich
erster werde machen wir weiter mit dem
bist du schlau Quiz von Jessie das hat
sie mir nämlich zugeschickt also Korn
unterstrich lugi und die erste Frage
lautet Biologie welches Lebensmittel ist
fett reicht damit kann ich mich relativ
gut aus Gummibärchen Pommes Marmelade
oder Lauch es sind tatsächlich die
Pommes
und es sind keine guten fette
ihr müsst ungesättigte Fettsäuren zu
euch nehmen Cashewkerne Avocados Leinöl
etc aber nicht gesättigte Fettsäuren die
in Pommes enthalten sind oder in Burgern
oder irgendwie sowas nicht gut Frage
Nummer zwei welchen Weg muss Siri gehen
um nach McDonald's zu kommen
[Musik]
immer seid ihr nur ach nee das ist ey
Siri geht doch immer durch den
Seiteneingang
den Fronteingang nehmen muss mcDonald's
hat immer zwei Eingänge jeder weiß dass
McDonald's
weil der wie kürzer ist weil der dumm
ist also das werden wir nicht die
Pubertät beginnt bei Jungen mit dem
Bartwuchs ja ich habe keinen Bartwuchs
das ist falsch
[Musik]
hier was ganz schlimm ne da hatte ich
nicht mal kleine Stoppeln
das waren so Videos die habe ich mal
aufgenommen das war die Rückwand von
meinem Zimmer und zu Hause und Bielefeld
da habe ich da mal die Videos
aufgenommen
auch wer ruft denn jetzt an Frage Nummer
vier Chemie wie nennt man Verbindungen
deren Moleküle nur aus Kohlenstoff und
Wasserstoff aufgebaut sind das sind
tatsächlich die Kohlenwasserstoffe
[Musik]
Chemie war ich nie gut
es war geraten Halbzeit meine Damen und
Herren doppelte Punkte weshalb schwimmt
Hexan auf dem Wasser also wieder eine
chemikalische Frage
[Musik]
Telefonjoker mit Siri und der Hecke
hexansch will auf dem Wasser aufgrund
des fehlenden Wasserstoffbrücken wegen
der geringen Dichte wegen den vielen von
der wahlskräften oder wegen der
Oberflächenspannung des Wassers in der
Oberflächenspannung
es ist das gleiche wenn die Dichte es
ist das gleiche wenn die dicht sorry das
geht wirklich nicht es ist das gleiche
wenn die Dichte von Hexan was auch immer
wahrscheinlich jeden Stoff wenn das eine
geringe Dichte hat dann geht es
logischerweise nicht durch die
Oberfläche des Wassers durch weil die
Oberflächenspannung ist also das ist
Quatsch Frage Nummer 6 von 9 English
let's talk the book let's talk above
over
ich dachte man sitzt sich gegenüber man
liegt zwischen ein Buch und dann redet
man over
das bodenlos weil eigentlich mache ich
alles richtig kannst du dich bei mir
entschuldigen Geographie das Klima im
tropischen Regenwald nennt man
ich zeige euch alle an das Klima nennt
man in der Tageszeitenklima waldklima
stundenklima oder Jahreszeit Klima ich
glaube Tageszeitenklima
[Musik]
weil das doch sich von tagsüber zu
nachts und ich habe wieder nur geraten
vorletzte Frage Mathematik verläuft die
Funktion nach oben hin oder nach unten
hin -1 plus X Quadrat du bist hässlich
perfekt dicker danke also wenn wir beim
x-0 Einsetzen startet bei -1 und wenn
wir eine Eins einsetzen
haben wir -1 + 1 haben wir eins wenn wir
zwei einsetzen dann geht's nach oben
ich glaube ich muss aber sein Abi
Auffrischungskurs belegen
letzte Frage im zweiten der drei Quiz
ist für heute welches ist die
Stammfunktion von FX gleich 8x hoch 3 äh
die Stammfunktion ist tatsächlich die
Funktion die der Stamm
von der Funktion
8x hoch 3
[Musik]
warum ist überall so ein C drin für was
steht das
[Musik]
zum Glück müssen wir es nicht begründen
weil ich habe wieder geraten schauen wir
uns jetzt allerdings mal das Rating an
mit den Podesten mal auf der 3D Idiot
wir können sogar vielleicht den ersten
Platz machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
allerdings auch schon zum letzten Quiz
für heute was mir die liebe Mona
erstellt hat was steht hinter der
Freiheitsstatue
[Musik]
wie blöd ist denn das also alles stimmt
irgendwie aber an Fragezeichen ist
Quatsch
das steht natürlich was hinter
die Freiheitsstatue ist zu New York
geneigt deswegen ist New York am ehesten
falsch aber hinter der Freiheitsstatue
ist Wasser hä wollen wir weiter mit der
zweiten Frage in Korea kann man kein
Foto von einem Mann mit Holzbein machen
wieso nicht man macht sich strafbar wie
ist das Holz an meinem Bein heute gibt
es keine Holzbeine mehr das ist
schwaches gezählt Leute mit dem Holzbein
Holzbeine haben keine Kamera
der Mann möchte nicht fotografiert
werden in Korea kann man kein Foto von
einem Mann mit Holzbein machen was oder
so
oh wieder falsch ich tatsächlich habe
ein Stück Holz wo der kleinen
McDonald's verzichtet seit Ende 2017 auf
die Zwiebeln als Zutaten stimmt das das
ist falsch
[Musik]
bei McDonald's gegessen weil der Opa ist
eigentlich von Burger King ach war das
ist die Scherzfrage an der ganzen Sache
hier oder wie
[Musik]
willst du mich verarschen Frage Nummer
fünf welcher Berg war vor der Entdeckung
des Mount Everest der höchste der Welt
tatsächlich auch der Mount Everest
[Musik]
aber ich finde auch popokarte Peter sehr
sehr super
welcher Song passt zu diesem meme okay
schauen wir uns das minimal an wir haben
entweder Infinity wir haben
keine Ahnung ne
gute Fragen aber
ich würde sagen müsstest
runaway vom sunstrope project das habe
ich alles noch nie gehört Frage Nummer 7
300 g Erdbeeren Kosten 1,80 €. wie viel
kosten 500 Gramm das ist drei Satz das
heißt 180 durch 3 sind 60 Cent das 1,40
plus das heißt 3,20 €
[Musik]
.
oh mein Gott ich habe so richtig
hergeleitet und dann einfach zu oh mein
Gott ich bin so ein Idiot letzte Frage
wie viele Museen gibt es in Berlin ich
glaube Berlin hat die meisten Museen von
allen europäischen Städten und zwar 250
ich hasse Berlin war oder falsch das
Maskottchen der Frauenfußball
Nationalmannschaft ist ein Koala das
stimmt tatsächlich
es läuft ja gerade Frauen WM deswegen
ich habe das gesehen letzte Frage für
heute meine Damen und Herren was
von den unteren stimmt Avocados sind
Beeren Avocados und Beeren
[Musik]
wenn ich hier nicht den ersten Platz
habe dann ist es scam weil zwei Fragen
war eine absolute Verarsche
[Musik]
auf der 3
schien auf der 2
ein Problem
[Musik]
[Applaus]